hi I'm Eric Voss and Rick and Morty gave
us its first look at season four at
comic-con with an exclusive clip some
descriptions of a second unfinished
animatic scene and some images released
earlier this week it's pretty exciting
to be breaking down Rick and Morty again
feel like I was a baby the last time I
talked about this now I'm just a baby
where it counts and my soul where were
you thinking I'm gonna break down all
the new things we learned about season 4
some fun background jokes from this new
footage and spoiler warning I guess if
you don't want to know anything about
season 4 and your fingers are stupid and
they hit the videos or things you don't
watch ok first there's this brief clip
from the new season featuring glooty a
new alien character voiced by thor
ragnarok and thor for director Taika
Waititi glooty is an intern helping
Jerry launch a new dating app and it
looks like this app has some
embarrassing problem with it that
requires it to be taken down okay glooty
take the app down kind of take it down
it's your app I'm just a Nintendo Wii no
apps have something to do with servers
so if you look closely the background of
Jerry's room on the dry erase board you
can see the apps name is love finders
with alternate name ideas like la love
and cupid derp and you gotta love that
dumb Titanic poster because we know from
the season 1 episode that Jerry is
stupidly obsessed with it
so my guess is that Jerry is put himself
back out there and he's struggling with
dating apps like tinder because he is
pathetic and weak and so maybe rick has
connected him with this alien species to
help him launched his own dating app for
losers but there's some horrible side
effect with it perhaps something like
that Silicon Valley episode where Pied
Piper suddenly took off but they
realized that other new users were
underage kids that they endangered we
say didn't put an age limit on it we'll
see so glooty is a software intern with
a don't develop my app tattoo on his
head and according to justin roiland his
alien species also features voice actor
Sam Neill you know Jurassic Park event
horizon both what titi and Neil are New
Zealand actors Roy Allen said that they
wanted a Kiwi flavor for this new
species that could also mean we'll be
seen another New Zealander who's been on
Rick aboard aboard Jemaine Clement
wells EP he's coming back so glooty
refuses to take them to the mothership
to delete the app from the
pervert but he does ominously say it's
coming and then there's this beeping in
him as if he's about to self-destruct
but okay okay don't hit me an ominous
beeping app you can't stay mad at a guy
with this kind of talent dad you can and
you have to okay so in addition to this
glooty scene the comic-con panel showed
a second clip it was an unfinished
animatic storyboard version similar to
that pickle Rick animatic a couple years
ago this one featured Rick making jerry
float through the air just out of
annoyance he says I wasn't born into the
god business I've earned it and then
when Rick and Morty take off the space
their ship gets a flat tire somehow and
then when Morty goes out to change it he
gets bitten by a space snake now this
could be the animatic from a cancelled
episode that Dan Harmon mentioned one
team to show at Comic Con in a recent
interview so this might not even be from
an episode in the upcoming season at all
as for other updates Harmon and Merlin
said that Paul Giamatti and Kathleen
Turner will also make voice cameos this
season and that a couple of meeseeks
will pop up here and there Kanye West is
still rumored to be taken over an
episode but royland and harmon have said
that they're still trying to work out
scheduling and this week we also got
some art for the upcoming season one
image shows Rick and some kind of grassy
alien field brushing his hands along the
stalks kind of like Maximus a gladiator
or a fan Osen Avengers in game and then
another image shows Rick with a bunch of
Crocky BOTS presumably these are the
relatives of the Crocky bot member of
The Vindicator Zemeckis these two three
I don't want to seem that all of these
are named cocky BOTS they might have
other variations like Robo dial who
knows Robo dial already a thing I'm an
idiot these images actually could just
be from the new opening credits for
season four as opposed to actual
episodes since the show runners said
that they don't plan to revisit too many
former characters and premises and
instead have their sites directed
forward to new worlds and concepts
comment down below with what you are
most looking forward to and Rick and
Morty season 4 and which overdone fan
bit you want to die
follow me on instagram and twitter at
gave us and subscribe to new rock stars
for breakdowns of all the big updates
coming out of comic-con right now and
more stuff about Rick and Morty as we
get closer to season 4 was premiered
this November they get for joining me
and who could you feel that breeze
[Music]